this box contains a precious but
dangerous cargo
this is the omicron sample thank you
scientists here believe it's the first
live sample of the omicron variant
they've been able to obtain
their first chance to confirm in the lab
whether the new variant is as worrying
as it currently looks to the world
outside we don't know yet what the
collection
or the constellation of changes that
we're seeing in this new variant mean
but we will
be able to test that now by taking it
into the laboratory
this high-level containment lab at the
center for virus research in glasgow is
one of the few in the uk equipped to
handle pathogens like this
it's only once it's inside that the
sample can be carefully unpacked
they've been preparing for this moment
since news of omicron first emerged we
can start straight away to put the virus
in culture in order to plan further
experiments later
because that's very important and this
is the kind of answer we need and we
need scientific data before claiming
anything about how this variant will
behave
so this is an important moment only
getting their hands on a live sample for
the virus will allow these scientists to
start addressing those urgent questions
about the omicron variant can it evade
our vaccines will it be more infectious
than previous variants does it cause
more severe disease
this lab like others around the world
has become expert at infecting human
cells with different variants of covid19
to assess their unique dangers
so on the right we have cells that are
uninfected and healthy and on the left
we have cells that we've infected with
styles curve 2.
but with reports coming from south
africa of possible infections of omicron
in people previously infected with other
coveted strains the focus has to be on
whether it can avoid our antibodies the
most pressing
is to be able to understand
how what is the level the degree
that this
omicron can escape
the immunity
elicited by vaccines so you can compare
for example delta versus omegron and see
how the the antibodies present in the
vaccinated individual can neutralize the
virus
however lab tests can only tell us so
much the view among these researchers is
in the weeks it'll take them to get
results it's best to prepare for the
worst while hoping for the best tom
clark sky news glasgow